hey you guys is chris witherspoon and
right now i'm joined by Noah Oppenheim
executive in charge at the Today Show
and the screenwriter of Jackie I love
this movie thank you so much he talking
about it thank you I want to know at
what point did you know you wanted to
make a movie about Jackie Kennedy since
I was a little kid my mom was a huge
admirer of hers and when I was really
young I went to my grandmother's house
and I found in my mom's older room a box
of these old newspapers and magazines
that were from that week in 1963 when
the assassination took place and it had
these obviously iconic images of Jackie
and the Black Veil leading this funeral
procession and I was just struck
immediately by them and fascinated by
her and so as I got older I would read
and learn as much as I could about her
and I just thought that like so many
women in history she had never gotten
enough credit and her proper do you know
people are interested in Jackie as a
fashion icon a style icon obviously
beautiful people are endlessly
interested in her marriage and the
complexities of that but she was a she
was an incredibly strong savvy
sophisticated woman and I thought it was
about time that somebody you know did a
movie that put her at the center of it
what were two or three the most like
surprising things you learned about
Jackie Kennedy in your research well by
far the most surprising thing I learned
was that she was the person who created
the whole Camelot mythology I had
thought that people had always referred
to Kennedy's time as in office as
Camelot or they done so when he was
running for office and I was shocked
when I learned that Jackie Kennedy's the
first person who referred to it as
Camelot and she did so in an interview
that she gave just a few days after his
assassination and so when I realized
that not only was she going through all
this horror after his death but that she
had had the presence of mind to summon a
journalist to her home and had created
this Camelot reference and and which is
stuck with us for decades it was an
incredibly smart move and reflected her
strength her sophistication and was just
a surprise to me because as I said I
thought that it had always been thought
of that way so what's this product was
finished once the movie was cut and you
texted you got to actually see now lead
four minutes stay your words yeah how'd
that feel i would say having Natalie
Portman read your words is probably any
writers dream it was incredible you know
the interiors of the movie were shot on
a soundstage outside Paris they
reconstructed the White House exactly as
it looked in the early 1960s and to walk
onto that set to see Natalie and you
know full hair and makeup to see her
perform those scenes it doesn't it just
doesn't get any better than that eyeless
jack somewhere I was real boys
[Music]
you